yo you know what's crazy is you you've  been smoking weed and i feel like when  you and i first started kicking it  you really weren't like a big like you  said you used to smoke back in the day  but at the time i feel like you really  weren't like really into smoking like  that not because like weed like so with  me it's weird it's like um it's cool you  ask that too weed is like one of those  things like back in the day i it was so  weird because like i used to be such a  big weed smoker and it really [ __ ]  with me not being that anymore i didn't  know who i was you know what i'm saying  without it so then getting it back or  whatever you know just spoken it tell  you a funny ass story and no so anyway  getting it back it makes me a little  paranoid yeah sometimes i'm having a  good time it depends where i'm with and  i don't like that weed weird [ __ ] yeah  but that never used to be me but it is  what it is it's honesty